and we hope that most of you will be
able to benefit from
the different resources that we provide
as we learn about metagenomics
so let me start by introducing what this
program
will be focused on we hope that most of
you
already have some background in
molecular biology and you will be able
to apply your interest in the microbiome
which is a growing and
very interesting and dynamic field to
learn how to
explore microbiome research projects
and look at different challenges that
are being addressed
using a variety of different techniques
this primarily includes metagenomic
sequencing
which refers to high throughput
generation of
short sequencing reads that could either
help us
provide a taxonomic description of a
particular
environmental sample or study in-depth
analysis of different genes that are
being produced by a community
of microorganisms now
the program is structured in such a way
that we will go from
learning about these different
applications and techniques
to developing an independent research
project
so we hope that even today and as you
get started with your learning
you will start thinking about what kind
of
data what kind of question what kind of
analysis you plan to do
and by the time you complete this
program you will either have a project
proposal
which we will explain how you can
continue to work on
after you complete the basic training
and join our research fellowship program
or even complete some of the analysis in
as short as
one to two months so to get started
let's talk about the history of
metagenomics and why
do we have these novel technologies that
help us characterize the microbiome
so let me give you a little bit of
history about microbiology
where the study of microorganisms led to
the creation of tools
and approaches that are still used today
and continue to uncover the veil
of a world which we do not see but yet
has such
a profound effect on everything around
us including our own health
so here you can see lewis fester that
lived in the 19th century he's a french
microbiologist and chemist and the
pioneer
of the german theory of disease back
when he was
involved in his research work he was
interested
in seeing the veil from the
microorganisms
being uncovered and really understanding
what is the impact of these germs or
these microbes
on everything around us and so the way
that this
first happened uh it was through
the microscope in fact uh the smallest
thing
humans could see was about as wide as a
human hair
and when the microscope was first
invented
suddenly we could see a completely new
world
of living things that surrounds
everything that we touch including
our water that we drink the food that we
eat and even
living as communities on our bodies and
so the first observation of a bacterium
was made around
1607 around 1673
by the dutch microscopist anton van
leeuwenhoek
thanks to the microscopes that he had
invented and these enlarged
from 50 to about 300 times whatever he
was observing
as the results improved more and more
representatives of the unseen world have
been discovered
and so you can see here an example of
today's microscope
they are tremendously powerful that
allow humans to see
smaller and smaller elements you can see
here in fact
a number of phages that are being that
are attacking e coli and bacteria so
this is the resolution that we are at
today
and so as a result we have a greater
ability to
see and understand the world of these
unseen microorganisms
but microbiology itself ended up being
defined
not only by the organisms that it
studies but also by the tools that are
used to study them
these tools are continuing to evolve and
have
already evolved to allow us to study and
categorize
organisms into our understanding
of the living world around us so
technology for bacterial culturing
coupled with a technique to stain
bacteria
first improved our ability to isolate
classify
and determine whether bacteria is the
cause of human disease
and even selecting today these fuels
continue
to develop and we can see a greater
resolution
into this world of unseen microbes the
discovery of culture media
allowed for the development of
microbiology in the 19th century
bacterial culture is an artificial
medium that allows growth and isolation
of bacteria
and the first to have cultured a
bacterium in a reproducible way
was lewis pasteur in 1860
gram staining is a bacteriological lab
technique
used to differentiate bacterial species
into two large groups
gram-positive and gram-negative based on
the physical properties of their cell
walls
gram stains are performed on body fluid
or biopsy when infection is suspected
gram stains yield results which more
quickly
than culturing and are especially
important when
infection would make an important
difference in the patient's treatment
and prognosis
so here we can see an example of what
that looks like
you can see how the bacteria is cultured
and then stained
and this ability to stain could be used
for example on
cerebrospinal fluid for meningitis and
synovial fluid for septic arthritis so a
wide range of different diseases could
be
characterized and accurately classified
using such techniques
the connection between disease and
microorganisms has been established
back in the 1800s but these studies
provided
not only important information but they
also followed a specific technique that
only could look
at bacteria in isolation but it became
apparent that most microorganisms
actually
live in complex communities many members
of this community are impossible to
culture in isolation
and they live and work together almost
as a single organ which we will learn
about in just a few slides
so that we know today that they
form highly regulated structurally and
functionally organized communities
that are attached to surfaces as
biofilms
with inter-species collaborations as
well as antagonisms
that contribute to their overall
ecological stability
due to the advances in metagenomic
sequencing
and other omics technologies enormous
databases of
data from such communities have led to
the emergence of computational
metagenomics
which can help study the 99 of
uncultivatable
organisms in the context of their
natural environment
so this is a brief timeline in the 1600s
we had the first
observations of microscopic organisms by
the 1800s
the connection between microorganisms
and disease has been established
from the late 1800s until present
culture
staining and microscopy were developed
and used in both
research and clinical applications in
the 1980s
until the present we have the emergence
of dna sequencing and the application of
dna sequencing to the study of microbial
communities
in 2008 the human microbiome project was
launched by the human microbiome
what kind of an impact this had on the
study of microorganisms
and from the 2010 and to present
bioinformatics and especially
multi-omics integration
have really defined the world of
metagenomics
the stability of these communities is
fascinating as many of us probably know
when trying to battle such common skin
conditions as eczema acne and dry skin
forming distinct communities these
microorganisms are interconnected
and determined to maintain their
community bacteria within a biofilm
can communicate with each other by
producing detecting
and responding to small diffusible
signal molecules in a process called
quorum sensing
which confirms benefit for host
colonization biofilm formation
defense against competitors and
adaptation to changes in the environment
quorum sensing activities in biofilms
are also involved in the virulence
and pathogenic potential of bacteria and
are therefore
an important factor in our ability to
understand and control bacterial
infections
as they enable microorganisms and
biofilms to become more tolerant to host
defenses
and antimicrobial agents inside each
community
there is a balance of bacteria fungi and
viruses that control species abundance
and activity so the human microbiota
is estimated to be between 10 to the
13th to 10 to the 14th of microbial
cells with around equal proportion of
microbial cells
to human cells previously it was even
thought that
that number is much greater but today
these figures have been adjusted
since 2016. these numbers are actually
derived from the total bacterial cells
in the human colon which is
approximately 3.8
to the 10 to the 13th of bacteria
the organ the gut harbors the greatest
number
of microbes however each one of these
microorganisms carries important
functional properties in genes that
contain genomic information
about different functions that our body
cannot
do on its own these properties and the
genomic information about microorganisms
have been
of a growing interest to the scientific
community
resulting in well over 80 000
publications in the course of the past
few years the majority of the studies
have focused on the intestinal
microbiome
so here you can see how the body is
dominated
by specific types of microorganisms
depending on the organ
and what we are discovering today is
that these microbes
actually communicate with each other and
form
almost a signific a single organ
that functions in a variety of ways
supporting our immune system digestive
system
and controlling the progression of
disease in fact
not so recently in february 2020
a new review article came out on the gut
skin axis
which summarizes the current knowledge
of the
interrelationship between microbial
dysbiosis
overall including the gut microbiome and
skin conditions
and it describes how inflammatory and
microbial
influences between the gut and skin
for a healthy state and the dysbiotic
state
are designed are a result
of a variety of microbial changes
so this this biotic state is
characterized by an
impaired gut barrier imbalance in the
gut microbiome reduced mucus layer
reduced uh secretion of different
antibodies
barrier disruption intestinal permeation
into the bloodstream and gut
inflammation
and an impaired skin barrier imbalance
in skin microbiome
reduced human and microbial
antimicrobial peptides
production skin rashes thickening
lesions
and skin inflammation and we can see how
gut and skin dysbiosis are connected
to an immune imbalance so in this study
you can clearly see not only the role of
the skin microbiome but the relationship
between the skin and the gut dysbiosis
in their relationship with the host so
it's really a very close
and interconnected organ now to study
this
there have been a number of microbiome
studies
that have significantly advanced uh
through major initiatives such as the
metagenomics of the human intestinal
tract
and the subsequent human microbiome
project these are
huge studies that have been made
possible
through the advances in metagenomic
sequencing which offers
a cheap alternative to study
microorganisms in their community
without the need of culturing and with
rapid turnover each new project here
represents
vast opportunities and challenges to
determine which microorganisms play
key roles in the development of certain
environmental conditions
needed for healthy function of human
organs and which can be harmful to it
specifically we now know of the gut
skin lung and even brain microbiota
that have been characterized and new
associations have been found
from mild conditions such as sensitivity
to different
types of foods to very acute conditions
such as the development of alzheimer's
disease
or even susceptibility to a variety of
infections
over the past decade more than 1.7
billion us dollars
have been spent on human microbiome
research
major projects are underway in the
united states
the european union china canada
ireland south korea and japan this
investment has
confirmed the significance of the
microbiome to human health and
development
some 20 percent of u.s investment in
such research has gone to two phases
of the human microbiome project which is
creating the research resources needed
to study the human microbiome
one of the main goals of the hmp
launched in 2007
was to create not only a data set but
also a toolbox of computational
techniques
analytical methods and clinical
protocols so that
others can leverage this to understand
the role of the microbiome
so what is known so far about the
microbiome function
is that it plays a significant role in
the differentiation of the human immune
system
oh sorry
let me start that over
what is known today about the microbiome
is that it plays a significant role in
the differentiation of the immune system
food digestion and nutrition energy
generation and conservation
metabolic regulation of fat storage
processing of environmental chemicals
maintenance of skin and mucosal barrier
function as well as prevention of
invasion
by pathogens so what we will do
in this program is we will try to
identify
how such microbiota could be studied
using next generation sequencing so the
essential steps here
are to understand when we have a
community that can be comprised of
millions of individual microorganisms
how can we use an effective approach to
sequencing the genomic information
about these communities to characterize
the composition
dominance or species richness and the
interaction between the microbiome
and their environment forming specific
conditions
that have have a major contribution to
our
human health as well as the environment
so what is the study of metagenomics
unlike other omics metagenomics does not
study a single organism
but the whole community at once so it
provides us
with a true snapshot of a collection of
organisms
that are specifically in the process of
interacting with their natural
environment
since the genomes are so diverse this is
typically accomplished
by sequencing a specific marker portion
of the genome
instead of all of the genomic material
present in a given sample
so specifically this is referred to 16s
metagenomic sequencing
where the amplification of the ribosomal
rna
from the smaller subunit of the ribosome
that is specific to bacteria can be
amplified using pcr
the 16s gene sequence contains
hypervariable regions
also known as hvrs that provide
species-specific signature sequences
that are useful
for bacterial classification the benefit
of amplification is tied to the nature
of sequencing read length
which can maximize effective output from
very affordable sequencing technologies
so the way that this data is annotated
and analyzed is through computational
processing which are called metagenomic
processing pipelines
so those are usually utilizing
something that's called operational
taxonomic units or otus
which can be used to classify groups of
closely related
individual reads the otus are
formed into groups of closely related
genomic sequences
and represent essentially a cluster that
could be assigned to a phylogenetic
clade
on the taxonomy of the full bacteria
that is present in a sample the way this
is done is by annotation
using different types of databases these
databases
include such repositories as the silva
green genes ncbi and rdp and so in the
context of this program
we will learn how to utilize these
reference databases to annotate
and understand what kind of composition
are we looking at in a given microbial
sample so ultimately based on that
mapping of specific regions amplified
from the 16s
ribosomal rna gene and the small subunit
of the bacterial
ribosome otus can be assigned to belong
to a taxonomic class of bacteria
yielding
important information about the
proportionate view of the community
each community can then be studied by
comparing with others
or between similar communities in
different conditions or individuals
such analysis includes an understanding
of how the different types of sequencing
techniques
and analysis of sequencing metadata and
data
could be combined together to really
understand the microbiome
now sequencing is not the only technique
that is used to study the microbiome
another technique is called mass
spectrometry
sequencing allows us to either
understand composition
or study specific isolated genome
and mass spectrometry can tell us what
types of proteins
and metabolites are being produced to
understand what functional contribution
each species might have
or what types of products a community
produces
and how it is metabolized through this
communal
analysis so many questions
about the role of microbiome members and
communities
are being answered using these
technologies and we
we think that the next phase of
microbiome research
lies in the ability to integrate
multi-omics data sets that combine
next generation sequencing mass
spectrometry
structural data as well as phenotypic
information about
overall changes in the community and
their environment
so many questions are going to be
answered through such integration as you
can see represented here
through both annotation of functional
pathways
and function as well as unsupervised
integration
between different types of microbial
taxonomy
different products that they produce and
the interactions between them that could
be studied using sequencing
so in this program the omics logic
metagenomics program
we will go through different examples
with associated training and practice
hands-on practice on how to use such
techniques to be able to analyze data
and interpret the results of the
analysis in a meaningful way
so to get started with this process i
want to show you
several courses that we have developed
for your asynchronous use
now as a part of this program this will
be supplemented by hands-on
activities that we will do in group
sessions for those of you
joining that have not signed up for the
program you can all
try out this introduction to
metagenomics course
to really understand how this works so
let me take you
to the platform and show you what is
inside these courses so this is the link
to our organizational page
again if you're already a part of the
organization you
could be just going to this
organizational page
and i will show you where to find the
associated coursework
so for those of you that are already a
part of the program
you would go right here to the courses
tab
and once you're in the courses tab you
will see
the three courses that we're going to be
covering in this program which includes
an introduction to metagenomics
metagenomics 1 and metagenomics 2.
so these courses have both a theoretical
review of practical assignments
and some data sets that you can go
through to understand
how the microbiome functions so here if
you
go to the course tab you will see
introduction to metagenomics
metagenomics one so you can start
working on those courses for those of
you that are not a part of the program
you can just go right here to courses
and you will find these courses
outside of this group so you want to
look for introduction to metagenomics
which is a free
course that will be available to all of
you
okay so introduction to metagenomics
right here
let me just paste the link here okay
thank you beeps you already pasted
introduction to metagenomics
so what is introduction to metagenomics
if you go to the curriculum tab on the
introduction to metagenomics
you will see here that we describe types
of metagenomic sequencing
analysis of 16s amplicon metagenomics
data
next generation sequencing and analysis
of ribosomal rna
gene sequences taxonomic classification
as well as the impact of microbes on
the human health the gut microbiota
the brain and others so this provides
a very thorough overview of a lot of the
things that we covered in today's
session
after completing this course you will
receive
a certificate of completion that you
will be able to
leverage in building your resume and
your capabilities
as a bioinformatician
so in other courses that we will
go through in this program you will find
additional
hands-on applications and
important examples that we will go
through so the way these courses
are organized is that you will see
the expectations for each one of the
activities
mapping of conceptual topics because it
can get quite
confusing with a lot of terminology and
a lot of very specific details that you
have to note
that's are being analyzed for which
reason
and how it will introduce you to a
variety of data sets or
projects that you will be able to work
through
and replicate analysis that was
published and described
in high impact research articles and
journals
and then those analysis pipelines will
become an
area for you to practice so that you can
understand the analysis not only by
reading about it but actually doing it
yourself
as a result you will accumulate a number
of points
that will result in levels and badges
that you will get for completing certain
activities
certification through our online
asynchronous
point system as well as in the context
of this group or of this program this
training program
you can also get a certificate of
completion
or a certificate of excellence which
will go to those that actually apply
these methods
to their independent project now in
these online
modules you will see how this key
terminology from a bioinformatics
perspective
is linked to examples of projects where
you can
analyze different types of conditions
that both represent a clinical
condition and some other examples that
are not related to human health
so what are some of these tools that we
will cover
in the in the metagenomics program we
will rely
on the t-bioinfo big data analysis
platform
that contains specific analysis
pipelines
or processing tools to manage
and analyze data from next generation
sequencing so here you can see
an example of a popular pipeline called
kinem2
as well as the data2 pipeline so these
pipelines
could be used to both process the data
eliminate the necessary junk or the
noise from the data
as well as do downstream analysis and
annotation
so to give you an idea of how this works
let's go to server.t
so beep said thank you for posting that
link in the chat
please let me know once you are
on this platform so that we could take a
look at some of these
example pipelines and for those of you
that do not
have an account yet with us you have not
received the email
we also have a demo account that you can
use that works perfectly fine it just
does not allow you to upload your own
data
so bips if you could paste the details
and for all the participants please do
let me know once you're on the platform
and you're logged in
all right thank you anita anyone else
you need to go to server
dot t dash bio dot info and
either use account details that you
received by email
or use the demo account with the
username
and password that beeps have posted in
the chat box
okay so as you're logging in i'm just
going to give you
a little overview of what you are seeing
here
on the screen for areas of analysis
so first of all you will see that there
are multiple sections for sequence
alignment
or sorry for sequence analysis listed
out
for each individual section so each
section represents
a collection of methods required to
process or analyze data
under some of them you will see this
drop down arrow
that represent the demo pipelines that
you can run
now these could be run both with your
account as a part of the program
or a free demo account that you might
have
so we will take a look in just a few
minutes on how to do that
then you see right here your previous
pipelines
so what are the pipelines that you tried
running or completed in the past
you will see right here your profile and
data management
so that you can understand what is your
account
and how you can upgrade and
you also will see here some data mining
utility scripts and machine learning
sections
so we will cover today a number of
examples just to understand how they
work
and what are the inputs and the outputs
and this will include whole genome
analysis
where we can map whole genomes onto a
database of known bacterial genomes
kind 2 is an example that i will show
you
as one of the most probably known
pipelines for analysis
of 16s ribosomal rna sequencing
and the data2 amplicon pipeline and what
are some of the
ways to annotate and interpret this data
using
a popular filoseek package in
r okay so let's go to the platform
and the first section that we will go
through is this section for metagenomics
microbiome so if you click
on this arrow you see here
demo metagenomics regular
okay so we can go in there and the first
thing that you will see
is this pop-up that explains what the
pipeline
can look like and what does it do and
what is the meaning behind
each one of the buttons and how to
really use them okay
so you can close this for now
and now we will take a look at one
example pipeline
that simply takes in some data from the
american gut project
which is the largest crowdsourced
citizen science project to date
because it involves many people from a
variety of backgrounds that have
contributed
their samples of saliva fecal samples
and others to understand microbial
composition
between a wide range of people after
you've selected this you click on
okay the second thing that we will do is
we will map
onto a reference database using bowtie
to align
so clicking here you will see that we
are mapping on a database called
silva and this is a database of
16s sequences so here you can click on
ok and then we will create
an abundance table using this annotation
method called pause count
which looks at the count of reads that
map onto a
particular entry into the database so
here you click on
okay and then we want to annotate
the positions in the 16s
rna database to understand abundance
of particular regions and how we can see
those
in our output files so here you can see
how we create a three-step pipeline
and then we click on end and we will see
what are some of the outputs
okay knee is saying that the
website is not responding could you
clarify what is not
uh working for you
so please put it in the chat if you have
some issues with
building this pipeline and we will try
to see
what the issue might be so after you've
done this pipeline you will notice
on top download pipeline output files
so you can click on this and see some of
the results
you will see mapping statistics which is
a process
of annotating how many different reads
mapped onto the reference you will also
see the result
of all of our bow tie mapping
and then you will see a table after
annotation
which is what we want to look at so
let's click on
table after annotation
and see the file that we downloaded so
i'm just going to
open this in excel and show you what's
inside
okay how many were able to generate this
file
how many people were able to generate
the result file
okay so if you have what you will see
is that after we have the
id okay so we have here the id
of this particular 16s ribosomal rna
entry and then how it is
organized by taxonomic classification so
here you can see
k p c o
f g s right so these are taxonomic
levels
so based on these taxonomic levels we
can now
organize okay so here you can see the
taxonomic
levels
how we took 16s ribosomal rna sequences
and we can classify them by species
genus family order class phylum or
kingdom and now that we
okay so kehinde just to kind of remind
you
what we did on the platform i'm just
going to show
one more time you go to areas of
analysis
okay again if you're not able to log in
please
use the demo password and
email account that beeps it provided
but here you will find once you're in
a drop down right here
next to metagenomics microbiome you can
also hover over this little eye
to really see what each section does so
under metagenomics microbiome we want to
take this first demo metagenomics
regular
once you're in here you will see a
pop-up which you can close
and in the future if you don't want the
pop-up to come up you can click on this
dashboard
then you click on start you read about
the
input data that we're using which is
from the american gut sample
bow tie to a line where we describe the
database that's used for
mapping pause count which creates an
abundance table and calculates how many
reads are present for a given
entry into the database and then
annotation so that we can annotate
based on taxonomic classification
so after that's done we click on end and
then you should see download pipeline
output files and you can open this
folder like that and now you see a
number of different
elements coming out in this output file
folder
so in this folder we managed to download
a file
that looks like this in this file you
will see that the result this is just
one sample so this sample
has a variety of different positions and
we can sort
by this column
to find the biggest
the most abundant entries into the
database
and so in this way we can start thinking
about
what kinds of bacteria are likely to be
present
in the sample and how do we understand
the impact of such bacteria on
the phenotype which is described by
metadata
now in this case this is a manual
pipeline where we take the downloads
as a table and then we can visualize and
annotate this
using a variety of different annotation
techniques
but let me now show you a different
example where this process
is automated and is specifically
designed for
sequencing of hyper variable regions
so to do that i will go into this last
section called amplicon16s 18s
and i will use this example project for
metagenomics amplicon
gut brain axis now it's called amplicon
because we are
amplifying hypervariable regions
and then annotating those hyper variable
regions
again on the same database but only
looking at the regions that are most
representative of this taxonomic
classification so here you can see the
process of
amplicon sequencing with pcr
amplification of variable
regions then you can see what the data 2
pipeline consists of which is primarily
the workflow to reduce
noise in our input data so that reads
are denoised merged by pairs
and sequencing and then organized into
clusters
of operational taxonomic units again
those are reduced from
chimers or chimeras assign
taxon by looking at the database
and then we can build a phylogenetic
tree
that can actually help classify
differences between microbiota so here
we use
an r package in filoseq that is going to
be used
for visual visual outputs of
this analysis so once i get to download
pipeline output files
i will see a number of different outputs
including some plots
which are given in a pdf format so for
example here
we see air plots quality profile plots
as well as filoseek plots so we can
download the filoc plots to see what is
the composition between different
samples
so here in filo seek we see
a family level
taxonomy that is distributed between
a number of samples six samples
btf010203 and then 13 14
and 15. and here we can see
the composition or the species richness
based on this
family taxonomic organization
so then we have to look at how
not only are they individually
represented
but also how are they interrelated a
species that is more divergent
farther away from another species is
more interesting than a species maybe
that is closer together because they
will have
a wider range of functionality
and so we build this tree of operational
taxonomic units and we can actually
study the different types of diversity
using additional methods like chao and
shannon
to understand how species diversity
as well as species richness can play a
role
in a particular phenotype okay so now we
have a question
when opening txt file data in excel is
it best to save it as
xlsb format or later retrieval
um okay seems like a question that's not
directly related to what we're talking
about but
yes overall you can probably save it as
an excel file
that way you'll be able to use it later
again easily opening it up in excel
and it will include saving any kind of
figures that you have in your data
that will be saved as well okay so in
this example
we're using a particular data set so to
give you an idea of some of these data
sets
i want to introduce a few different
applications of the microbiome
that we will use in this program
but before i do that i also want to
mention
that we will use some of the methods
that we've seen here
including philosophy and the different
methods that are packaged within this
package
as a way to learn a little bit more
about coding so now to see an example of
how we will leverage
these examples in metagenomics to
understand
coding and popular packages in r and
python
let me take you to another resource that
you will gain access to in the context
of this program
called code omixlogic.com
okay so if you could please put that
on the chat thank you other tyler
so please go with me to code
omixlogic.com
and here you can register for free so
this is a free account that you can
generate
and i will explain in a couple of
minutes how this works and how we will
use this
for generating figures that you see here
on the screen
okay and for anita's question we will
learn about the simpson
index and the shannon index they have a
different ways of calculating
differences between the sample
composition but those specific
differences could be interpreted in
different ways
depending on the type of input data
we have and depending on the question
that we have
okay so let me know once you are logged
in or you have created an account
on code dot omixlogic.com
okay if we could again post that link in
the chat with
https it will be a link
okay so let me know once you're on your
account
on code logic.com
all right let's see some people started
logging in all right great thank you
nita
all right thank you jeremy and lydia
all right great so once you're in the
account
you will find a course called
metagenomics so in this course
you will see some of the examples of
what we will be using
to amplify our understanding
of the microbiome composition and
species richness
but also learning about some very basic
functions in r so in this course
you will find how to generate
a an understanding of what types of
bacteria are present in the sample by
proportion or by abundance
and what are some of the typical
considerations
around leveraging the different outputs
from the pipelines that we already tried
so that your understanding of the
composition is also
considering the abundance of input data
that you have
and the sequencing depth that you are
using
in maybe a different set of samples that
you're using overall
so in this course you will find
different practical tutorials
and let me just show you how those work
okay so once you're here
you can see here a variety of other
courses that you
obviously will get access to as well but
here let's just take a look at this
example
and we'll go right here to number four
and so in this course you can see
that we start with an introduction of a
data set this data set includes a
variety of different cons
conditions and as an example we can use
those that exercise
rarely and those that exercise regularly
okay you will find in the source data
set which is
linked right here a variety of different
metadata
that also include how often people
eat how often do they drink how
uh what is other kind of lifestyle
conditions that we could link with
microbiome composition
and so once you read about this let's uh
go to this practice yourself you cannot
open this unless you actually
complete the previous steps but here
you'll see an example of what this
how does this actually work okay so
just by simply clicking on this run
button
you will be able to try out the code
that is here and so obviously
you will be able to modify the code
as you try to arrange this data
in such a way that you can prepare it
for
a publication or presented to your peers
comparing composition by different
taxonomic
classes between different conditions
okay so here you will find both
an explanation of the challenge
the code basics as well as
a practice playground where you can try
to modify this code
and produce the types of results
that you would like to use in your
publications
okay so what is going to be included
what we'll do is we will look at a
variety of methods
as well as an understanding of the
typical considerations
behind the statistical analysis as well
as the machine learning
methods that are typically used in
analysis of omics data
as well as specifically for meta genomic
analysis
and we will go through very basic things
to learn how the code works
as well as very specific applications of
the most popular packages
that are used in metagenomic analysis
so let's talk about several examples
that we will use
as data sets to practice
so applications of metagenomics include
analysis of skin conditions food
sensitivity of the gut
autoimmune disorders cancer
antibiotic resistance drug resistance
and even ecological and agrobiological
studies
so we'll take examples from skin and
acne
sensitivity of the gut microbiome and
these different conditions
to play around with the different
methods of analysis and understand
that in the context of different types
of questions and data sets
we should use appropriate methods to
process
and annotate as well as visually present
our data
as i mentioned one of the first projects
that we'll try
is from the american gut project
so the american gut project is a citizen
science project
that has a lot to offer for those
interested in basic
and microbial composition of different
types of samples
from healthy and mildly sick individuals
here we will learn how to create a
report similar to what you see right
here
for an individual that submits their
data
and also how to group people by
different types of composition
of their microbiome to study a condition
however in this example it is very
difficult to
disassociate the impact of microbiome
from other factors that are not related
such as behavior
comorbidities and other unreported
data that we have associated with each
sample
so to study the effect of microbiome
changes
in a unique way we can turn to a project
that we will use that tries to
characterize the relationship between
the
gut and the brain axis by studying
microbiome and behavioral anxiety
so here we will see how changes in the
gut microbiota
in mice through antibiotic treatments
followed by a gavage of donor stool from
other mice
can help us determine if significant
behavioral changes are induced
and anxiety levels are associated
specifically with microbiome that comes
as a result of
high fat diet or a regular diet for mice
such studies are really important for
our
basic understanding of the role of the
microbiome
as well as in the translation of
different types of
probiotic prebiotic and
transplantation strategies for treatment
but we will also look how microbiome
or the kind of microbial community that
we're studying
can have a variety of other types of
effects and for example we will take
use cases from tuberculosis ebola
and even rhizobacteria which is a
bacteria that grows on the roots of
plants
and how to study such data importantly
we will see that the microbiome is now
considered to be
a major player in many other areas of
biomedical research
for example screening for diagnostic
signatures in precision medicine
and even association with treatment
efficacy
or the therapeutic considerations for
microbiome transplantation
to study such can conditions as
alzheimer's disease so here you can see
an article
where china has already approved
alzheimer's treatment that targets the
microbiome through transplantation
and so importantly we will not only look
at processing
individual types of data but we will
look at how bioinformatics
plays a major role in our ability to
organize
analyze process and find associations
between
clinical and onyx data or phenotypic and
omics data
to find important translational insights
about diagnostics therapeutics and even
agrobiology
because today we know that the
microbiome in agriculture
is considered to be an important
component
of production of different crops
resistance and resilience of crops on
harsher conditions that are caused by
the climate change as well as the ideas
about
how to develop novel interventions and
provide better security for food across
around the world so here we can also see
how the applications of microbiome play
an important role
in what's going on right now during the
pandemic
many studies have turned to microbiomes
role
in susceptibility and immune response to
covid19
and this is an important part because
the microbiome
is one of the easiest things to sample
in the human body and so this provides
us with a unique insight
into a variety of fields that have a
direct
impact on our lives so in the context of
this program
we invite you to master metagenomics
data analysis
so after you complete the program you
should be able to find
analyze and interpret metagenomic data
on your own
and you will be able to gain experience
by doing this
in the context of our interactive
sessions and hopefully if you have the
time to present
your project proposal to also do this to
our community so now i want to open this
up for
any questions that you might have i do
want to mention that
introduction to metagenomics and some of
the coursework
on the code omixlogic.com coding
playground are accessible for free for
those of you that have not yet
registered for those of you that have
registered
you have access to a lot of additional
premium resources that will be provided
in the context of this program
and for those of you that have
registered i want to recommend
that you already start building up your
profile
from starting to complete with your full
name
to adding a photo or an avatar
and then starting to accumulate points
so that you can get certification for
the different resources that you
completed
and also gain recognition for the work
that you do
again two types of awards will be
at the end of this program a certificate
of completion or a certificate of
excellence
and so as you think of your questions
i will just briefly explain what these
two mean
the certificate of completion will be
awarded to anyone
who has over 3 000 points which
equates to about four different courses
um and obviously some practice with the
pipelines that are required as a part of
the course
certificate of excellence is awarded to
anyone who has over 10 000 points
so 10 000 points is an easy goal
for someone that is going for an
independ
independent project so if you are
willing to
not only learn about metagenomics but
also
find the data set and try to analyze
this data set and understand what this
data set says about microbial
composition
you are likely to find yourself easily
achieving this 10 000 point goal uh
because
uh your practice with the coding
and with the different types of
pipelines
those will likely to end up quickly
accumulating into ten thousand points